we have an update from
criminal justice reform you know i've
been doing these sort of regular updates
on criminal justice reform because we
are told the the worst problem in
america is over incarceration and the
criminals are the real victims and we've
got to focus on what we as a society
have done to force these people to
commit these crimes so i want to see how
this is going because what we were told
was
if we go softer on the criminals and we
let them out of prison and we let them
get away with their crimes then things
will improve the crime rate will go down
we'll all live in harmony we'll sing
kumbaya and play in drum circles
together so has that happened uh no
in one of the latest attacks a brutal
and unprovoked attack a
young man relatively young man 40 year
old man was caught on surveillance
footage at a seattle subway station
grabbing a 62 year old woman kim hayes
and throwing her down a flight of cement
steps
this was at the chinatown international
district station
hayes this 62 year old woman is a nurse
she's worked at a nurse for a long time
she was going in to this hospital to
work and then around noon time so broad
daylight right right at lunch this guy
comes up flings her down a flight of
cement stairs
well how could we have predicted this
look michael crime happens okay you're
not gonna you sound just as utopian as
the left there's no way to prevent all
crime that's true but i think i could
have predicted this one because this guy
alexander j
has been convicted
22 times
of crimes in washington state and
california
and it wasn't insider trading okay we're
not talking about white-collar crimes
here we're talking about violent crimes
he was convicted of burglary theft
selling stolen property drug possession
auto theft multiple counts of domestic
violence
well michael maybe that was all in his
past don't you think people deserve a
second chance
i believe in second chances i don't
believe in 20 second chances
but maybe it was a long time ago maybe
he paid his debt to society oh no it was
just last year
he was just last year convicted of a
residential burglary
he's been issued more than 15 bench
warrants since 2016
by washington courts and he failed to
attend his court hearings
this
guy
should not be allowed in society
forget after the 22nd offense the 21st
after the third offense what do they say
in baseball one
two twenty two strikes you're out no
three strikes you're out
if this guy's gonna keep committing all
of these offenses at the very least he
has to be locked away forever from
society at the very least
that's the that's the most moderate
punishment i could imagine
it's not good for him
he's out there doing horrible things to
other people and to himself he's not
living a flourishing life he's harming
himself his soul probably his body and
for what he's going to end up back in
jail they're probably going to let him
out and he's going to go throw another
60 year old woman down the stairs
criminal just there it is there's
there's our over-incarceration problem
there are these poor beleaguered
criminals our problem we're just too
tough on these guys he never had a
chance no the 62 year old woman never
had a chance because you let these
animals run around society after 22
prior convictions it's not it's not just
one or two incidences we've got a guy in
yonkers
guy in yonkers new york that's a town
just north of new york city
guy in yonkers
here's the new york times story from
this attack up in yonkers man hit woman
in the head 125 times because she was
asian officials say
67 67 year old woman wearing a white
face mask and dark hooded jacket and
pushing a shopping cart enters an
apartment building in yonkers new york
as she moves to unlock the door a man
comes up behind her and hits her in the
head with a roundhouse right hand the
force of the blow knocks the woman to
the ground as she lies there her
attacker bends down and pummels her
repeatedly with both hands for the next
minute more than 125 blows altogether he
then stomps on her seven times and spits
on her before walking away this is one
of the most appalling attacks i have
ever seen says john j muller the yonkers
police commissioner
to be the helpless woman is despicable
targon here because of his race makes it
more so absolutely right so this guy was
just a totally unpredictable
one-off attack right there was nothing
we could have possibly done to stop this
crime happens and oh no he had 14
previous arrests half of them on felony
charges according to the yonkers police
convicted of assault in 2011 sentenced
to just over three years in prison
released on parole after two and a half
because he's such a good guy
then he was released in october 2013
according to state prison records
and then he just keeps committing crimes
why was this animal let out of prison
because of compassion because he's the
real victim and the woman who almost got
murdered by this savage she's you know
she's just kind of part of the system
the institution the society and boy
didn't that society fail this poor man
gosh we got to do something about all
this over incarceration this leads
to not just bad outcomes for the victims
and for the individual at least about
outcomes for the society for the whole
community
i'm so glad you like that clip now
please please i implore you ring the
bell subscribe get the notifications for
every video we put out best thing you
can do is go over to apple podcasts or
stitcher or spotify or wherever you get
your podcasts and subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind
and we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]